i thank everybody for your forbearance
uh we have reconvened now
in public
there's quite a few recommendations for
us to go through but we have the report
uh from rhiannon welcome back
thank you hope the health is a little
better um
we'll be as expeditious as we can do you
want to take us through
uh give us an overview of the report and
the process from here rihanna
thank you chad kiara councillors um yes
so this report
um provides you the opportunity to
consider all
of the submissions that you've received
and heard
the changes to the operational
environment since the time
of consultation and the recommendations
from offices for you to consider
in response to all of the feedback that
the public has provided on the long-term
plan process
so the report um goes through the issues
in the order that they were outlined
within the consultation document
so issue one was the city center and
urban play
issue two the southern museum and art
gallery issue three rugby park
issue for all of the projects within the
road map to renewal
issue 5 other activities which was the
link to the infrastructure strategy
issue 6 which was feedback on finances
and revenue plans issue
seven the proposals to change the way we
rate
and then i've added an issue eight which
has all of those additional requests for
support that have been received as part
of a long-term plan consultation
process so i'm recommending that you
deal with these
issues slightly out of order so
issues one two three four five and then
issue eight so issue eight is those
other requests for funding so the logic
behind that is that you deal with all of
those amount
issues that relate to expenditure and
then come back to deal with
the proposals to change the rate and
finally
what that means in terms of implications
for finances
and the level of rates itself
so the report does have six
recommendations
so recommendation four deals with the
majority of the recommendations linked
to the long-term plan i'll just note
that
recommendation five relates to all of
those
um all of the
allocations that you made for external
funding prior to consultation so it's
recommended that you just deal with
those as well
at this point um so those were the
requests that you received
prior to the end of last year
so in summary this paper really is an
opportunity for you to deal with all of
the issues that have arisen
as part of consultation make those final
decisions prior to audit coming back
and finalizing the long-term plan with
the feedback from audit
and then it will come back to council
for adoption
and for the rates to be struck on the
30th of june
so today is really that opportunity to
make the final decisions
as you're all aware this is a process
that's 18 months long
and has been long and building to this
point
made many decisions over the previous 18
months
and this really culminates today um
prior to us then spending the next two
weeks finalizing the document and the
budgets that sell
so i'll hand over to michael just to run
through the
um financial overview and the um
changes to the operating environment
before we move on to issue one
through yourself cheer
just waiting for the presentation to
come up
so councillors i just want to set the
scene for what
where we are from a financial position
as we stand right now and also
what was consulted on from that
perspective and then just give you a
snapshot
in relation to our capital program
however before us
go through that i just wanted to
highlight
the time frames and we were at so
my collar grin has given you an
indication that we're about to move into
the audit process
as we go into that i remind you our
chance for any change post now
is very slim the once we hit the audit
phase only really significant items will
be addressed by audit at that stage so
i just want to urge council today as the
day to get things on the table to
actually
get those decisions through
so as we went out to consultation our
position in relation to the rates
increase was sitting at
a 5 rates increase on average across the
city
with those uh five years before post
that and then down to three
just wanted to remind council that was
the opening position
how that looked across the city with
distribution
in property types we had had a look at
look at this from a council perspective
with a very clear focus to
focus in on low value properties and
trying to distribute the rates
slightly differently in relation to a
policy change that policy change
has has been in the consultation and
we've got some recommendations in
relation to that
further in the day
a further reminder about the position of
our debt in relation to a council
we have been prudent from a council
perspective i pulled council on there
and setting their net depth position at
a lot lower than
most other councils from their
perspective we've only gone for uh
150 which in
we can actually increase it to 250 from
that perspective but
that comes at risk and of course comes
at the
necessity to increase rates to actually
service that borrowing so
keeping rates at the lower lower end was
the preferred in relation to that
borrowing
capacity
last thing i want to draw council's mind
to so they can have a
good discussion about today is the
capital program as it sits
um i want this is something that was
raised by
our the auditors in relation to delivery
there's a lot of items in today's
discussion around
what is required to actually increase
our delivery from a
council perspective but it's important
to look backwards and look at what we've
delivered in the past
and look at the program that is before
us in the consultation
i'll draw the attention to 2016-17 which
was
council's previous largest year that
included
one significant project in it which was
a land purchase from that perspective
but it was still quite a significant
year as well we had some big
construction in that year
and when you then look through to
2021-22 it is a significant
uplift in our delivery and i've listed
the
key key projects that have been included
in the consultation
and the roadmap to renewal down there in
relation to
those works i'm going to highlight that
that is a
significant increase and you can look at
this year we're at 20
forecasting to be at 26.5
you'll see items in
in the paper today that we'll talk about
how we can achieve that and how we can
improve the delivery scope but any what
i wanted to
raise with councils any change upwards
from this would put a significant burden
on on possibility deliver that is an
ambitious target
that's one item the other item when it
comes back to the financials
just want to highlight there any change
to the capital program
if you're wanting to look at trying to
create capacity into the program
anything would need to be shifted
outside of year four
to create that capacity from that
perspective
um anything staying inside the year four
does not actually
alleviate our challenges from a
financial perspective for the opecs
any we are at a position with the
recommendations that are before us that
we're still within
that five percent at the moment any
further changes
will require an alteration in relation
to the rates and i will need to
go away and model that for this
afternoon so just wanted to highlight
that and that's
that is any change so no no matter how
small so
just wanted to raise that council thanks
michael it is
um a significant scale
of increase that i don't think can be
undersold and it's it's been
drawn to councillor's attention
previously
um you know that's a big leap from our
biggest year
uh in 1617 uh double what we're
doing in the current year and this is
for for next year
and even then 22 23 is is
at least double what we're doing this
year so it's
a huge jump in the capital works program
for a few reasons that have been pretty
well signaled um taking advantage of
uh government funding that's available
um
a post covered or post lockdown uh is
is one of the opportunities that's
triggered a bit of a reshuffle but
also uh noting um
comments around uh change that we can
bring in now and and you can as we go
through the issues
uh and debate them make change but that
there is
an effect from that but if we're going
to make change today
really is the day that we do it
any further questions or comments
rhiannon
you're fine michael
nothing else right
uh i think we can probably do the first
three recommendations relatively swiftly
i'll move though it's quite a quite a
scroll backwards
sorry yeah i would like to move those um
uh first
three recommendations regarding
streetscape i'll second those
sorry the first three are just actually
about uh receiving the report
sorry all right one two and three
sorry i thought you two i'll second
those thanks
question your comments around that just
proceed you'll put that all in favor
against carried
uh so some of these will take in groups
and some of them will take individually
depending
on the interest of councillors and
wanting to discuss them so
we'll look at the streetscapes first are
we wanting to take streetscapes
separately or a
b c
i think a b and c would work together
for a streetscape
um i have a comment or question on b yep
that's fine so
councilmember is moving the first three
i'll second that to get that on the
table
thank you councillor crackit um my
question is for officers around um
the recommendation how it speaks to a
focus on dispersed play
um as it was my understanding from
reading quite a lot of the submissions
and um also hearing from our submitters
uh that the the hub and spoke um
focus was was something that came to the
fore
um that given that there would be a like
a hub
playground with a spoke focus with lots
of dispersed play
around that and having having it
interconnected
so um in terms of the feedback from the
consultation
of course it's qualitative feedback and
so that's
why the proviso in the report that says
that this is
it's not something you can give a
specific amount on
um i would say that marginally more
people were talking about dispersed play
now whether that was specifically around
a hub and spoke
model i think i understand what you're
saying there that you've got a core
playground and then some options that
are linked to it in some way
so um there were some people talking
about that
as an option while they weren't using
the phrase
hub and spoken necessarily
but on balance there were certainly more
talking about lots of different
locations rather than one
specific location but but there were
lots of different ideas
coming up in the comments so the
recommendation
is looking at developing scoping a
report that includes that dispersed
player as well as a
as well as the hub yeah i guess i'm just
tentatively
worried about um the recommendation as
it reads because then
if we say that it's a focus on dispersed
play than that
um that precludes us from doing anything
that isn't
dispersed play i guess so um having a
focused playground
with dispersed play options to me um
as i would like to see as one of those
options rather than
just dispersed play i don't think it
calls for just dispersed play but it is
simply a scoping report so it's
it's the first report in that next stage
comfortable with that there's no
decision it's about
asking for for a report
yeah if we could just add the word
options
in there i know that's a little bit
semantics but i would just feel more
comfortable with that
to be honest i'm sorry to the chair um
we weren't actually looking to lock
ourselves in at this stage as to what
dispersed
play would look like in terms of whether
or not that meant
a an area that was larger than the
others or whether or not actually the
dispersed play model would be
several areas of similar sizes
um so that's why we haven't gone to that
extent yet that we want to explore that
through the auctioneering side of things
okay councillor partner
i was just around if uh going for
a sit play area would require
a substantial amount of land now that
would then
incur cost which is not budgeted at all
in the streetscape so i mean what we're
trying to do
what i see this is trying to do is
trying to use the budget that we have
here
to work and and give us this
play option thank you
rebecca sorry i thought you
know hearing any feedback on that um
yes yes i would i definitely agree with
that comment i think there's there's a
couple of things one is that we want to
also
see what the effect of the play aspects
that we're already integrating into the
streetscapes have and how people
actually react and interact with those
as well as the fact that the the budget
that we have
isn't one that allows us for a you know
a large
margaret mayhe style playground with
several dispersed areas as well
um we would be looking very much more at
that that
multiple smaller play interactions
throughout our streetscapes place
and that's very much also the feedback
we've had around the
streetscapes process in terms of how we
actually move people into different
areas of that space
counselor sopher having listened to
what's just been said i'm just wondering
whether we just put a full stop at
request offices to further develop
the scoping for urban play full stop
i think that gives officers the wide
ability to bring back what
we've just been hearing about
uh while i'll entertain the idea of
mover and secondary
you'll just need to refresh me whoever
is the second director
yeah look it was going to move things
along i think that leaves that open i'd
be happy with that
okay so with your agreement of mover and
second
four b stops at urban plane
council arnold
sorry i just noticed the mic went on i
thought yeah you had something to say
oh and i was just gonna um add my vote
right brace for impact
any further discussion on those first
three items
if not it's been moved and seconded with
that amendment
uh i'll put that all in favor
thanks alan carried
4.2
deep breath we move into
a b c
d
e we deal with all the museum
items or do you want to take them
individually
individually individually okay well
let's start with a
first option is confirm the first um
recommendation is we confirm the
preferred
option to invest 39.4 of a 52.5 million
dollar project to
reopen and refurbish the museum
councillor pottinger
um right well i'm going to go straight
in here with
an amendment and the amendment is not to
it's not on the table yet so
it's on the table okay i'd like to move
an amendment
it's not an amendment it's not on the
table so you can word it
i'll change the recommendation yeah yeah
okay
what i'd like to do just purely 4.28
listening to the
submissions we had some strong verbal
submissions
on a new museum
and and the very first submission of
first cab off the rank was joseph mclean
who spoke passionately and said build
new and build smart
and i think i'm in favor of the
following recommendations
i just think to give um
the team who are going to be steering
this i've got a lot of faith
in wayne marriott and steve giblin and
when it comes to 4.2
c i think that group will just need
the freedom that if if new is better
then then we need to just get rid of the
word refurbish
and uh it just means uh the wording i
would have here
is confirm the preferred option to
invest 39.4 of a 52.5
million dollar project to open an
invercargill museum
to open or reopen no open just to open
i'm happy to second that
i think this is this is really important
because this is the i've been here
11 years now on council and this is the
first time i have seen
a museum upgrade project in an ltp
it's never got there before so this is
this is going to happen
and i think i think fate has
you know works in a funny way and i
think we're on the right track
to deliver a very important project
and i shouldn't be speaking to the
future
bc and dna now but
i might as well is
that time
i think that extra year is critical but
we've got one chance and needs to be
done right
so that's important for me
thank you i can assure you it has been
here before but only in an amount of
funding
yes it's not not as an ltp you know
no in an ltp
because the council had to be the first
organization to commit funds through an
ltp process for the first version to get
underway
but obviously not to this detail
however if we come back to the
recommendation that you're putting it's
confirmed for 4.2 point a
confirm the preferred option to invest
39.4 million of a 52.5 million dollar
project to open the museum
correct correct so you're moving that
second by councillor amundsen
erin thank you chair
um no concern in general with the the
change to the recommendation i would
just
note the risk that the report that went
to council last
year around options for the museum did
have a museum
option of a new museum it was a new
museum with the existing
footprint that we currently have but
that was at
a significantly higher budget than what
we have
in that recommendation i definitely
think that there is
room for greater efficiency in
bringing the footprint size of that
museum down
what i would flag to councillors that i
wouldn't have confidence at this stage
though that with a smaller footprint
we would necessarily be able to deliver
a new museum
within that 52 and a half million dollar
budget
so that's something we would need to
explore so just on that point steve
can i ask you uh for comment around
that there's one right there steve
isn't my handheld there around the
dollar amount
is it better at this point that we just
give ourselves a little bit more
wriggle room i think i'd have to take
aaron's advice on that as from a capital
program point of view
um look the conversations we've had
early days with the funders
um we know that that the funding gap is
going to be quite a challenge
anyway and if we want to create a
certainty on that envelope
certainly closing that funding would
help
michael do you have any comment around
the funding
show yourself the chair yes of course i
do in relation to that
as i mentioned very early on
any increase in relation to that in the
first four years is going to have an
impact
and this is scheduled to have a
significant
cash outflow in those first four years
so any increase will have an impact on
my numbers to model um in between the
break and come back
counselor clark then councillor lewis
okay we're
we're gonna start with us um so i'll
just talk initially to the uh
the amended um issue that we've got up
there
when i listen to what's been coming
through the submissions
um one of the overwhelming things is the
time frame for getting this done
and i notice in here we're looking at
the end of 2627 which is
by my assessment at least six years away
and possibly longer
so i i can't buy into that having said
that i did
suggest yesterday a new museum on the
tennis courts
right next to the existing museum had
some merit and the merit for that was
putting aside the time frame for it was
that it
removes our ability or need to find
immediate storage for the for the
collection it could stay in the pyramid
museum
um we could potentially lease part of
the pyramid museum out at a later stage
for other storage purposes
as well and it gives us a new building
um i'm not convinced by the report we
got last year
around the cost which is what aaron's
referred to because at that stage we
were asking the engineers and quantity
surveyors
to give us a like for like comparison so
we were asking him
if we did a new build and we compared it
with the existing pyramid what would the
cost look like and the cost was
75 million so it'll be 80 or 85
and i think that's unaffordable um and
so
one of the issues was if you take away
the like-for-like comparison and you
consider that
maybe if we had the uh we took out the
storage capacity which was part of that
like for like
our new new museum which uh councillor
pod just recommended
could be 10 15 20 less than the current
one if you factor
out the storage facility and in fact it
may be more than that and that might
bring that
um 75 million down to around about 60
which i think is
affordable i've raised this before and i
know it's caused michael some heartaches
but the long-term plan has got a base
underline of 40 million dollars in
reserves
and we've got 49 million in reserves at
the moment so that gives us another nine
that we could plonk into this
this project and we could be quite
realistically
looking at a funding base of around
about 60 as opposed to 52
and i think that would give us quite a
unique little
new museum here so i'd support that so
long as the time frame is not the same
at the moment
in my wildest dreams i cannot understand
why we need six or seven years
to get scope a new museum and get it
built
given the time that's taken for the
langlens hotel and the public don't have
the stomach for that
so i actually do support the
recommendation but with a caveat that
the time frame needs to be much closer
and i know i've heard the staff say
yesterday and today
that we have to be very mindful of what
we've got at the front end of this long
term plan and audit new zealand
raced out as well so this is not a
matter of just looking at each
recommendation in isolation i have some
other considerations for later on
that push back some of these projects
that are not high priority
the overwhelming support we got right
through this process
and through the stuff we did last year
around
the research document that we got came
back overwhelmingly
that putting aside the city block and
streetscape
everybody wants the museum at the top of
the list so we've got to make space and
time for that
and funds and if other things drop
further down the plan than so be it
thanks i'll just remind you of the
advice that we were given as
well around capacity of some of those
key
infrastructural projects that are
contingent on government funding that
we've got to make sure that we meet
as well um and and the langlens hotel
was about five years in the planning
before they even started to drill
councillor lewis then of partners thank
you mr chair
i would be very much in favor of council
pottinger's recommendation to be
carried um i've had experience in major
renovations
not as big as a museum and i know this
tends to be an overrun
of unseen problems i know we have
structural engineers looking at it
but we haven't had a definitive quote
about any of that and my fear would be
that the renovations
would actually escalate quite
substantially
so i would be definitely recommend a
favorite version for
council pottinger's recommendation
councillor pottinger just i'll just
check to see if there's anybody else
that wants to speak otherwise
because i'll come back to you as the
mover with the final word councillor kit
yes i'm very nervous about fixing up an
old building
that's probably 70 years old and you
strike
problems i was involved with
a grandstand at the racecourse at the
moment
and it's been added to over the years
it's leaking with water
this problems galore so uh i know what
uh what it's like because we're having a
meeting tonight at 5 30 regarding that
facility so i definitely support a new
build
we're not at that point yet we're just
we've got a motion that's giving us that
as an option councillor sofa
thanks mr chair um i do support
the um the amendment because i think it
does two things
it confirms the investment that we
consulted on
um and to my mind reading all the
consultation documents that that
particular
amount did come out as the majority
support from people
and it then leaves us with an open mind
on the further recommendations from
b to g of how we are going to
best use that for the people of
invercargill so to me
what we're confirming is that we are
determined to open
an invercargill museum and we are
determined on the amount of money that
we consulted on
so i'm i'm in favour of
going for that recommendation and in
conjunction with the further
recommendations in this
area i think that we have a way to move
forward and get the best result for
invercargill
thank you councillor partner thank you
chair look i appreciate
uh councillor clark's um expediency on
this thing
and uh and it's probably thanks to um
his perseverance that that's got us here
now
um with with this in front of us uh the
options
look in 4.2 c it states that a report's
coming back on 25th of june
so that's timing that that is
very close and then that that group will
then have to
proceed and bring back the the options
that are
that we will go for either the
refurbished or the new or whatever
so look i actually believe it's going as
fast as it
possibly can
and i'm quite happy to if we need to
ship back a couple of projects like the
water tower or something
that that are not as urgent so
i just wanted to speak to councillor
clark's concern
i'm with him on that but i see the
project is
going as quick as it can because again
i'd like to just
restate that it's more the quality
of this finished product that we've got
is more important than a year either way
for me thank you there's one
item that i'm really seeking a little
bit of clarity on and that's in the
motion
the option to invest 39.4 of a 52.5
million dollar project
and yet i'm just resting on a figure of
60
million that was uh mentioned councillor
clark i think you
you raised it um
that just recognizes where the project
may well be so do you want to
just expand on that a little yeah just a
little um
and i agree with that councilor partners
just said i fully support this
um but i just think that 52.5 might be a
bit light and if we're asking staff to
give us some feedback by june which is
great
that we should listen to what aaron had
to say which was basically that
52.5 may not get us a new build
so i just wanted to push the boundaries
out a little bit doesn't mean we're
committing to it
what it's saying is that when you go
away and report back to us in about a
month's time
you know give us some scope about
whether there's a little bit of
ability to dip into reserves so you're
suggesting that
as a much much like your initial motion
sort
a bit more wriggle room and openness
uh unless the mover and secondary
comfortable with that second figure
going to 60 million of a 60 million
dollar project
okay i'll call a brief adjournment for
for five minutes in just a second
rhiannon just before just to clarify for
everyone's understanding the
recommendation for to point c
is that there will be guidance brought
back on the 25th of june for what the
governance group will look like
obviously they will not have
been formed and provide be providing
advice at that point
on the actual option for the museum just
to clarify
yeah thank you okay yeah councillor
clark just very quickly
just two quick issues one in relation to
what council of cyber writes
um i think we were a little bit shackled
in the long term plan around the options
that we gave for the museum we basically
gave option c
and we gave them a clayton's option of
doing nothing uh while we went out and
put a bit more money into hee wakatooya
and i think that was a flaw and so i um
i think it would be helpful to
to reopen that options which is what
council partners said to look at
option d as well um and get some advice
on that but i mean i don't want to be
sitting here three months six months
from now and
and the community's saying well what are
you actually doing about the museum
because we've
we've known about the earthquake
strengthening since i think from my
memory 2012 2014
so that's best part of a decade and we
they just want to steer on what we're
going to do and if it means that we
have a rate impact in one year or two or
three years as opposed to
but further down track i just think we
need to bite the bullet and get on and
get it done
thank you we'll take a break for german
to five minutes
erin the floor is yours thank you chair
we've just had a discussion just around
confirming the budget amount
in option 4.2 a there's obviously been
some discussion
around the process to reimagine the
museum that we need to go through and
the fact that we'll be setting up
an external governance group to work
through that process with us
at this stage i would suggest that we
could continue to move forward with
recommendation 4.2 a
and that budgeted amount as it stands
that will give us the opportunity to
work
through that reimagining process and if
we get to the end of that process we are
finding to councillor clark's point that
we would be proceeding with a new build
and that requires additional budget then
that's something that we could address
through our long-term planning process
so we'll do a variation at that point
but at this stage we can move forward
with that process
with the current budget cool thank you
for that clarification
uh mr chair i wonder if erin also wants
to speak to 4.2
c and the need for
yes so um i might actually pull up steve
giblin to speak to 4.2
c yeah thank you through the chair
um look in regards to pulling this
governance group together
what we're recommending to is that we
we've identified
the allocation of approximately sixty
thousand dollars to support that
governance group
which would see an independent chair
being appointed
to lead a group of local stakeholders
through that reimagining process
uh that work would obviously kick off
the beginning of next financial year and
this would be part of the report that
will come to the june 25th
meeting but we're just highlighting this
now as
just to bring this into the budget at
this point
thank you so that brings us back to the
original motion that we have up there
which is not the one on board books but
the one from council of pottinger
um you can see it is 4.28 it's been
moved and seconded
and with that clarity thank you to the
staff i'll put that all in favor
all right against carried thank you for
that
uh 4.2 b is confirming the preferred
location for the museum remaining at
queen's park
now on that i also don't think that it
locks us
in it's about the preferred location it
doesn't say the final location so with
that explanation i'm happy to move it
i think i think you've made a good point
that that that it all depends on
what this final decision is so i think
that's wise
so with that actually should we do bnc
together
really uh councillor sapper i'm happy to
happy to agree to that is the secret
thank you
uh rhiannon and can we add the amount
into 42c the 60 000
recommended budget allocation
yes sorry i was getting confused between
60
000 and 60 million the last
thank you mr chair um just just on that
since 42c suggests the staff are going
to come back to us with the suggested
setup of the group
i think that would be the time to put in
the
like the um costing amount rather than
include it now
okay councillor clark um two issues
through your chair um
one issue is the makeup um of the um
governance group um i would hope that
that we get a broad spectrum of people
and potentially someone in the business
world as well that we just not
solely focused on the art fraternity
because my experience in the last year
or two has been that's quite a
fragmented
group um so with different views
and secondly what's missing in this
cluster of uh
four to a through g is that when we set
up
the well when we set up the group we'll
get the paperback about the group on the
25th of june
there is nothing in there that tells us
when we're actually going to get the
report from the group
so is it going to be six months down the
track a year down the track two years
down the track
whatever so i think we need to lock that
group into giving us some
definitive thing because this museum
cannot just go on
into the future without some sort of
definition of what we're going to commit
to and when
i think that advice will come on the
25th of june
the the makeup of the group the terms of
reference and how long they've got to
to prepare but your point is well mate
i could sorry i just for the point i
could i could live with the
recommendations on the governance group
but i think we should
give that group now um some mandated
time that we expect to get a report back
i think the museum's gone on for too
long
michael thank you
through yourself the chair just a point
of clarification on the
financial amount um waiting until the
25th
is leaving it too late from giving
clarity for the ltp we actually need the
clarity
today um even if it's um putting in a
provision for that
that group to allow us to move forward
from today
if that changed on the 25th then that is
something we can discuss with audit but
we need a clear stare today
thank you rebecca i'll come back to you
councillor claire
uh i was just going to comment i guess
in response to councillor clark
about the time frame these time frames
are going to be in the ltp about how
long
and how quickly the museum needs to get
done
so that should guide the governance
group surely
councillor clark yeah just as a final
comment on on the advice we've given by
michael
um yeah i wasn't suggesting that we were
pushing up
the um potential rateable amount to 60
million dollars
what i suggested originally was that we
have some
capacity within our reserve funding
which is currently sitting at 49.5
million dollars
that and our ltp is based on 40 million
so we have some discretion there
and so he's quite right we could put a
striker rate at the end of june
for five percent or whatever it is and
we could still
fund the extra three museum without
going to the rates we're just looking
to fund everything through a rate
increase where in fact
we have other sources of revenue that we
can use and if we ever want a rainy day
to in this city in the next 20 30 40 50
years
it's it's in this next period when we
finish off the
city block and the streetscape and the
museum
everything else is minor compared to
that
thank you so i'm just following on from
the comments made by mr day
and i wonder counselor so but whether or
not you're comfortable with
an addition coming up at the end of 4.2
c and an amount of 60 000 dollars be
allocated for this work
i was about to say that which is why i
raised my hand having had the advice
from mr day yes i would be happy to add
that
so that becomes part of the motion then
with the mover and secondary in
agreement
everybody clear on that okay so we're
moving
um b and c together i'll put that all in
favor
aye against
carried thank you councillors that
brings us to
[Music]
d i'd be happy to move dee
mr chair i'd happy to second it
thank you moved and seconded no comments
counselor pottinger um look
having just gone through the process
with streetscape
and um you know selecting the preferred
contractor and the designs and
everything and that was done
at speed of light and it worked it's
gone really well we've got good product
i'm just i'm i'm a bit with councillor
clark a
i think up to a year but i would like
that to be
the ability to get that shrunk if the
work is done
obviously um
can be done a lot quicker i mean i'm
i'm just seeing what happened with that
project
and we've got a good product delivered
and it's happened quickly so
i just think uh it says one year can it
be
up to one year mover and secondary how
do you feel about that
is this recommendation
going to affect the budget because if if
we make it vague and say up to one year
doesn't that mean that the ltp budget
has to put a question mark beside the
amount
of money that's allocated to that year
for the museum
and won't that make it so technically
from a budgeting perspective you're
still pushing it out of here
but what you're doing is saying if it if
it's finished earlier in that
that would be good and i guess that's
the stare that councilor pottinger is
talking about um
uh suggestion for mrs hadley is not bad
confirmed delivery of no more than one
year later
i would be happy with that i wouldn't be
happy with the other version but the no
more than one year later i think is
achieving exactly what
other councillors are talking about and
it fits in
with the whole point that we're talking
about at the moment which is the
budget delivery we say no more than one
year
we are making it clear we're not talking
about it sagging into 2007-2008
so as the mover i'd be i'd be
comfortable that it said no more than
one year
councillor clark yeah i'm opposed to
this this whole
4.2 point d um i believe that
three years from now which is well into
the cycle of six years
we will be reviewing the long term plan
again i think it gives a wrong message
to kick this further out
if you think about what council's
already approved around the water tower
in 2018 and we haven't touched anything
there
from a public perspective we haven't
done anything even though in the
background we may have done some scoping
and anderson's house again we proved
that through the infrastructure
committee recently and
again the public seeing nothing
happening i just think this gives the
wrong message
we will have a chance to review this
whole project
in three years time in a six year cycle
and i think what was in the long term
plan was a recommendation that would be
completed
in the 2025-26 year
and and that's what i would support i
won't support one that goes one year
longer
okay noted um but i will also point out
the comments that we received from the
auditor
uh not only around this project but
around all and the challenge of meeting
the time frames that we've got on our
ltp
uh saw another hand up down there was it
you counselor lewis
thank you cheer anything we can do to
get the museum
completed earlier the better because
we're going to have the
i'm not saying we make a resolution to
change dates necessarily i agree with
the not late in the one year
but as long as it doesn't send a message
out because we're going to have to
deal with contractors and we work with
shortages perhaps
even material shortages as we progress
the amount of delays
uh availability of contractors is being
shown right around new zealand at the
moment so anything we can do if we focus
on
trying to get on time to whatever time
we decide rather than
given the option of trying to allow for
any delays
i think the focus has to be on getting
it done on time
as soon as we can i don't mean by
tomorrow but
as soon as we can and that's the general
feeling out in public i believe
thank you yes i wouldn't disagree with
that obviously everybody's is keen to
see the doors open
as quickly as possible however we've got
uh a motion
uh is there any further discussion on it
if not
i mean once it started to be built then
obviously it finishes a year later that
that's not the big deal
it's just to get the project underway
thank you councillor arnold i'm putting
the motion uh sorry as the mover yes
before you do that um
the motion has not been changed
sorry that was the speaker the mover who
went there i don't think there's
anything else we can add i'll put the
motion all in favor
all right against yes i'm against
thank you i would like it recorded
counselor
arnold which way were you voting were
you supporting the motion or
i'll support the motion thank you uh 4.2
e
i wonder if we can yeah i'm happy to
move those last three
e f n g they all kind of go together
yeah
thank you move councillor emerson
seconded councillor abbott
[Music]
so sorry it's over a split page there
but we haven't changed the text at this
point from what's sitting in board book
so that's kind of useful as well it's
open for discussion
there is none that makes it uh
expeditious
put the motion all in favor aye against
carried i'll park my thesaurus
4.3
do we want to do 4.3
a and b together i'm happy to move that
way mr chair excuse me i'll leave the
table uh
thank you you don't have to leave the
table if you just signal that you've got
an interest
zip my lips yup thank you councillor
keith noted
moved councillor soper seconded
councillor skill it's open for
discussion
clark uh through your chance um
it doesn't seem to be any designation in
here and
um and four three about um the
commencement dates which the other ones
do have
so on going back to the long term plan
it was recommended that the
rugby park renewal be 20 23 25
i'm of the view that stage one which is
just a strengthening of the building
should be earlier than 2023 it's
creating us problems now and
historically this is one of the projects
that's been sitting on the shelf for a
long time
it's my understanding that when we took
over the park the ownership of the park
in
2015 we already knew it was earthquake
prime then
and had a series of reports since then
and we haven't done any remedial work to
resolve that
so i think that needs some urgency and i
know
um some around the table may really
think well we're bringing too much into
the front end i've got other projects
that need to go further out
to accommodate this so i think that
stage one
should come back up to the 2022 period
not 2023
and beyond and that stage two which is a
more of a look at how we develop the
park for future use
could be pushed further out thank you
comments
noted remembering of course that
shuffling that around does impact
how we are spreading the rates over the
term long-term plan
are there other comments counselors
if not a and b have been moved and
seconded i'll put that all in favor
aye carrie thank you councilman
i'd like your focus because there's no
there's no time frame
thank you mr chairman
has it been recorded that i didn't
participate it has
thank you do you want to add the year
to the motion 44 sorry 4.3
a in which case in the current plan it's
23
24. sorry the vote's already been taken
mr chair i think in writing the report
rhiannon included the years if there was
a change
from the consultation document but has
not included them if there is no change
proposed
that was the rationale thanks
councillors it brings us to 4.4
a and b just by the way i'm planning on
taking a break at 10 30 not me
personally but all of us
[Laughter]
trust you mum taught me to share um
talk to himself but we can get through
uh
this next one certainly uh anderson
house 4.4 a
and 4.4 b i think we can take together
councillor scout has indicated you're
wanting to move there
thank you and seconded councillor sopa
those two items are open for discussion
councillor pottinger i think this is the
prudent move
it's essential that that we act on the
water tightness
uh painting and not let any uh
further degrading of any of the external
materials
so i fully support this i think with the
and
and the view with the other options for
the venue
it's it was a real tough one lifting and
listening to the submitters
um it it ended up after uh
after that that it actually can't be
used
really for events it's it's uh sort of a
monument of something
and even if a wedding was to be held
there it would be held in the marquee
outside
so it's something of grand splenda that
we need to protect and i think
over this time period it will allow
certain individuals if they come up with
ideas and and funding
to uh to come to us and then look at
further use but that's it's not
council's role i don't believe
we need to take responsibility in
preserving this
and then the next step will unfold
thanks i'd agree i think it's time to
just be prudent
the suggestions from submitters were
that we should just get the doors open
but until we actually know what they're
open for
uh securing the safety of the building
by making sure it's watertight and doing
that basic maintenance before doing any
uh
capital expenditure that might need to
be redone
for another potential use isn't best use
of money at this point
councillor arnold was that a hand up or
were you just lunging
just lunging thank you councillor lewis
thank you chair
there's no mention about the foreign
house at the back of anderson's park is
that included in the budgets anywhere
they haven't seen
because i believe that's um compromised
with
boroughs or termites or something there
was a claim that came from
one of the submitters but we haven't got
a paper to confirm whether or not that's
the position
councillor scout thank you through
youtube
i think it's a really positive move
we've made this morning
um just from clarification erin um
through discussion yesterday it was um
incredibly pleasing to hear that
that's possible and movement with the
contractor
or contractors that we could possibly
start some week by the end of the year
can you just clarify that for the public
that
that's possible yes absolutely so
where we are at with the anderson house
project is that we we have completed the
design and we have lodged the consents
for this one
uh we did go out to the market for
registrations of interest in
february we only got one party who
registered interest
and then as we completed detailed design
and developed the program they weren't
able to meet a program of completing
that work
this year we then went back out to the
market to see if we could get others who
could complete
this year to which we couldn't um we've
then looked
to work a little bit more flexibly with
the market around whether or not they
could start work this year
completing it in the first half of next
year and at this stage we have
several interested parties around uh
progressing forward with the tender
process around
around that so we're just finalizing
that process at the moment
with a hope to as we say uh commence
that work
um in the latter half of this year
thanks erin
that's incredibly positive news here and
a big thank you to the team because
uh i know the public expectation is high
and uh
you've got it across the line for us so
thank you
any further questions or comments
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against carries that gets a and b out of
the way 4.4 c
might provoke a bit of discussion so
i'll propose that we
take a 10 minute break at this point
thank you councillors
that brings us to 4.4 c
uh an increase in the budget from 1.4
million
to 4.1 to make the water tower
earthquake safe
and extend the project into the 22-23
year
councillor amundsen i'm just wondering
whether we need to push this one out a
bit further to give ourselves a bit more
breathing room given that we've got
so many projects in that
list of 70 million that we were shown
earlier
and given that this is quite a
significant increase
to the amount that was required as well
that maybe you know we can't do
everything that we want to do all at the
same time
and maybe this has to be the sacrificial
lamb in this case
thank you councillor abbott then
councillor scout uh thanks for that uh
concur with what uh councillor ahmanson
said
it's gone from 1.4 to 4.1 million it's
an iconic
institution i agree with that it's a
landmark i think it can stay as a
landmark
and the priority i would like to see
would be that shift of money to the
museum
can i ask a question of the staff about
when
might be the best year to shift it out
too
if we were headed to erin
um through your chair yes there's
definitely
capacity to move the water tower out
to the latter years of the long-term
plan
what i would suggest is that we are
currently in the latter stages of
detailed design
for this project so there has been
obviously budget expended to get us
to that point i would suggest that we'd
want to finalize that detailed
design package so that we've completed
that full stage of work and got the
benefit of that investment
so that would require approximately
three hundred thousand dollars of that
um one point sorry 4.1 to be retained
um we could look to move it out i think
as far
to about the year eight of the long term
plan within the regulatory standards
however i guess we just should note that
it is a building that obviously
is there does present a risk and um
if we do have an event but it is
obviously within the vicinity
of the road um and within a reserve
area so there there is obviously some
risk that we are taking on
continuing to delay the strengthening of
that building
councillor skelton councillor clark
thank you to you just concur with
hearing the other points she's made just
to clarify your inform yesterday the
earthquake risk in the sense of the
liability
to cancel the date was 2027 or 2037.
uh it would be i don't think it's 2027
it's slightly after that
um but i'd need to just double check
that one thank you and for you michael
just
uh in charge of the chocolate wheel just
by pushing out the
financials on that if we went out the
four well i think you mentioned the
five-year cycle
we pushed it into the next financial
from a business model we're looking now
that would alter the barometer on the on
the chocolate wheel going forward
through yourself the chair yes that is
correct thank you
councillor clark just to want to support
the motion and and recommend that we
have an amendment that goes out to the
2026-27 year
um like my colleagues i think uh the
cost is uncertain yet till
erin finishes her work um and we just
need to take the
pressure off the front end as audit new
zealand have suggested we're probably
too ambitious at that
first four or five years so i'd
certainly be quite happy to kick it well
out it's not a high priority for me so
is your suggested amendment including
allocating a dollar figure of uh i think
400 thousand dollars
correct 300 thousand dollars
thank you uh who was the mover
well i kind of suggested it but are you
comfortable with incorporating
those changes into the motion yes
absolutely okay
so do i understand that the motion will
now read
retain three hundred thousand dollars
for the 21 22 financial year
no so what it would what it would
actually be as it's 300 000
is the total cost to get us to this
stage we would want to retain
100 we've already spent approximately
200 000 on the building
we would want to retain a further 100
dollars to complete
the work so retain a hundred thousand
for the twenty one twenty two
twenty one twenty two yeah to complete
detailed design complete detailed design
work
with the remaining three point
three point nine three point nine
million
uh sorry the remaining sorry it's four
point three point eight
million sorry uh in the
twenty six seven i think was what counts
twenty twenty six twenty seven
that's fine can i ask are we better
off for budgeting purposes
to not be specific about the year so
that when michael goes away in the break
to
miss things around um he has a bit of
flexibility
about when exactly that is the best time
to
pop that back in was that useful uh
through self cheer look i'd rather a
clear stare from council give me
direction on when you would like these
and then i'll model it from there
and if i've got um concerns i'll come
back after the branch
you need to spell complete yes all right
it's shorthand typing at the moment as
we go
councillor clark just one quick thing
for michael i think yesterday you said
to us that
uh our rates were sort of roughly five
five percent for five years and uh i
think
three years for five percent this year
for
dropping down to three percent so
where's the three percent cut off is
that
0 8 20 28 and if it is would if we're
pushing out projects would it be more
helpful to flatten the rate impact out
into the
years that you're predicting three
percent
which i think is what somebody else is
alluding to
through yourself the chair yes it is 27
28 that we do drop down
to that point um but it's more around
the
borrowing levels that hit hit that peak
it's not so much around
your right side of it i've got a way up
um rates affordability as well
okay in relation to that the benchmarks
we have on that so
okay i'll need to do that through the
break as well sure rihannon
just to note that all other amounts and
the recommendations have been inflation
adjusted
so um that 3.8 million is not yet
inflation-adjusted for moving it back
councillor pardon you well thank you
chair look i think there's a bit of
water to go under the bridge with this
project yet because it's gone from uh
uh seven hundred thousand dollars uh 60
33 to 1.4
for 67 now we're looking at
4.1 and i believe this 4.1 actually
incorporates
uh admission to the tower
and you said and anything that when you
have a project that all of a sudden
has admission then surely there would be
an operating
budget needed to go with the tower
because you're not going to have
just an open door policy with people
running up and down stairs and going in
and everything so i imagine it would be
man
so i don't see any allowance for
sort of an activity for this
so i think there's a lot a lot of work
to be done yet and i appreciate
what's going into 4 4.4 c thanks
i mean personally i think the the leap
from 1.4 to 4.1
uh set me up and and part of the as you
say was around
access um and you know the best part of
three million dollars for
um a small number of people to be able
to
stand on the top and have a look out
when we've got pressure from so many
other projects just didn't seem
like good use of what funds we have
available
certainly i'm conscious of of erin's
comments around the stability of the
building
because it's next to an arterial route
it's next to a heavily used footpath and
the last thing we want is it actually
dropping on someone but do we need to
get to the point where
um people are able to go out on the top
and even then there's disability access
that's going to be affected into account
i'm at that amount of money i'm not in
that space personally so i'm
comfortable with the amendment as as
proposed
so the amendment is done with the
sorry it's not a myth of the that's the
original motion
uh includes those changes alan
counselor arnold did you have a comment
to mate
just listening no okay
sorry when your hands flash up like that
it's
it's a signal that you want to say
something so actually i'm just moving
sometimes oh yes
you should be sitting here stuck to the
seats
okay with that understanding i'll put
the motion then all in favor
carried thank you councillors brings us
to the
uh funding allocation for the active
recreation precinct uh 4.4 d
somebody wished to move that i can move
those
thank you are you just that one or you d
dna together thank you seconded
counselor sopa open for discussion
if there is none i'll put the motion all
in favor
against carried
we probably should have taken f in there
as well shall we uh
we'll just have to move f separately now
f is to do with surrey park
can we sorry if i missed something yes
we've missed something can can we put
the word sorry park into if please
thank you so we haven't got something
there so we're adding surrey park to f
now it makes a whole lot more sense and
we haven't missed anything
i'm happy
so just check the changing uh
text on the screen so we're including
the one point
retain 1.5 million in the budget for
surrey park
and defer this project two years to 2324
in order to undertake for the
consultation and scoping directly with
impacted groups and that was the clear
stare that we got through
the consultation as well it was actually
useful to see
the users coming together and giving us
the same
steer so with that change it was moved
councillor sopa seconded
sorry councillor scout any further
discussion
councillor clark and same same
line as we had with the water tower um
would be my recommendation that we
pushed this out to 2627
um i've had some experience with the
sock club that's been under that stating
for a long long time
um and i don't see any urgency for this
project
um there's not a significant risk the
building's not
crumbling over the top of them um it's
something we should push out again
because audit new zealanders told us to
be
or suggest that we're too ambitious at
the front end
i guess the concern was around the
safety of the people using the
grandstand not necessarily wahoo by afc
councillor partner well actually i
i agree with councillor clark there is
more work to be done just besides
the actual use of the stand and
everything because we also talked about
access coming in off tay street and the
decongesting of the
the back of the uh the main state um
invercargill stadium so i think there's
a whole whole raft work to be done there
and not just around the users of of the
particular thing
i think the whole complex when you look
at it from a bird's-eye view
needs careful planning so then that's
not going to happen on that time frame
so what i'm going to draw your attention
to is
that the motion merely talks about the
scoping report but not the
the delivery of the project so what it
is
uh that they come back with will have to
be fed in uh
2324 and it might be the next ltp
process it don't be the
amendment to the long-term plan through
the annual plan process
so the motion leaves
the ability for all that to be
incorporated we're waiting for them to
come back
with the suggestions it's not the
completion of the work and the
suggestions may
involve different
funding requirements around what's
happening with the grandstand club rooms
uh orientation of the grandstand and the
use of the grounds around it
yep councillor scout i just asked uh
mr gibbling with that process have you
just mentioned councillor
would that be from your workings with
the groups would that seem to be a good
roadway pathway
forward time framewise to get that
information
yeah thank you through the chat look
that's that's certainly the clear
feedback i think we heard last week
through the submission process and it's
also the feedback we've had individually
with those clubs
is to take our time and do it once well
and i think this
recommendation gives us that direction
thank you councillor clark yeah just one
final reflection
um i think what council potluck said was
right
when we listened to the stakeholders
down there which were predominantly
soccer and
athletics what came up as a backstory
was the
whole issue around the stadium itself
and the lack of car parking and the
congestion area key events and so
i think there is a wider picture we need
to consider so the more time we get i
think that would be helpful and we look
at access and and potentially more car
parking around the back side of the
south side of the stadium as well where
there is potential
i think it was the entire surrey park
review yep yep
councillor scalp just to clarify for
councillor clark just there has been a
whole lot of work done by council around
the car parking
of tay coming in so there's been some
previous work
maybe steve you're not aware of that
just coming in but there has been a
quite extensive piece of work done
around the car parking issues at surrey
park
in particular off tay coming in so just
clarifying that situation so that formed
part of the original surrey park
review that we've just gone through
and i don't think that was the item of
contention from the
from the users councils are going to put
the motion now
all in favor aye against carrie thank
you for that
uh 44g
move that way mr chair
moved councillor sopa seconded
councillor amonson and can i just make a
comment
yes um i think that this is a good move
i just wanted to note
in the commentary it says that there
were only a few submissions on aci
um and i just think that sometimes with
these projects that have been in more
than one
ltp we need to remember that when it was
first consulted on in the last ltp there
were a significant number of
submissions in in support and in favor
of something like the aci
and maybe we need to just include that
comment i guess in future documents
i think it's just a case of constantly
refreshing counsellors through this
process i mean i did it earlier on
uh around the museum and the long-term
plan that it had been there but merely
just
council's financial contribution but
it's a valid point that councillors need
to be reminded of that was a significant
steer through the last ltp for the aci
so it's been moved and seconded are
there any further comments or questions
from councillors
i'll put the motion all in favor aye
against
carried pulls the additional pull
i'll move that
counselor abbott seconded oh secondly
councillor lewis
it's open for discussion
there is none i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carrie thanks for that
new river estuary um i'm comfortable
with we're just
it's calling for a report back on the
discussions that are going on
it's not requiring any funding so it's
pretty straightforward somebody want to
move it
happy to move there sopa seconded
councillor pottinger
i'll put it all in favor hi hi harry
thank you
o'malley road
recommendation there so for discussion
counselors if somebody wants to put it
counselor lewis you're moving it i'd
just like to discover
i'll move it but i'd like to discuss it
yes absolutely is there a second
difference
secondly second councilor kate thank you
councillor lewis i am concerned about
the safety of this road but the way it's
been described to us
uh whilst ceiling is moderately
expensive i know
i think if we don't go along with the
ceiling until much later
we need to spend a lot more time on the
general maintenance of it
so with that aspect has to be looked
into i think
whichever way we go on the on this
particular motion
it's quite a dangerous road as i've been
down at several times
and it's easy to go off the road the
next recommendation about the the speed
limit may overcome some of that but it
still won't stop the danger of tourists
and people going down to
the end of the road so um with the mover
and second can we take the two of those
together
thank you um i think you're right and i
think when the the
the item comes up for review there are
options that can be considered
just in my observation of going down
there there's two really tricky parts to
the road one that corner
where there is undeniably you know
pretty bad rutting at times and then
there's
as you just go over the brow of the hill
into maui itself
but a temporary solution might be just
um looking at sealing that corner and
dealing with the the routing the rest of
it comes down to driver control in
vehicles and driving to the conditions
um but you know the feedback from the
residents is right there's a lot more
people that are going down that way
and and many of them are folk who aren't
necessarily used to driving on gravel
either
those are just intended as comments
we've got a recommendation
on 4.5 b
nc councillor bottinger um
through the chair can i just ask what
the current speed limit
is down there russell
100 kilometers per hour is open road you
might want to pause and
on gravel on here on gravel right
good luck yeah
i don't know i grew up in south otago
it's quite doable
even on corners like that but not safe
councillor skilled are we going to the
next can we go to the next item or i
just want to ask a question of russell
just around that
100k wrestling net on that road
is that a
are you dealing with this and two yes
okay so the speed review is part of the
motion okay so just that speed review
obviously russell from your experience
and knowledge where would you see that
given
other council's concern around the the
safety of the road and so on is there a
recommendation around that from
from your group certainly in the maui
road and the makamaka road
and the same with every gravel road or
every road is that you need to drive to
the
drive to the conditions and the the
issue with 100k
speed limit is that they are on all
gravel roads across new zealand there's
no
unless you specifically change them
downwards so once again it's actually
traveling at the safe speed
for the road and as part of the speed
view that is the question
that you pose to the communities is what
is the safe safe speed that the
community wants for those roads and
that's brought back through that bylaw
review
given the government is also looking at
some of the how you change some of those
rules
um eg around schools in other words
there might there may well be other
changes but
at the moment um gravel roads are
treated as 100ks and you travel at the
safe speed
there is as
c indicates a review planned for early
next year but it's it's like this
morning you know people could drive at
50 kilometers per hour on the roads if
they wished
not necessarily a smart thing it's a
limit not a target
so we're comfortable around b and c is
there any further
comment or questions that counselors
have
if not i'll put the motion in favor
against carried
uh 45d dump station at bluff
there is none i'll put that all in favor
against carried
4.5 f and g we take those two
together um
when we hit it that way mr chair thank
you councillor snoper
councillor lewis councillor scalp i've
just done
the electronic scoreboard just by point
in the sense of the event
and procurement and so on if if that
could have been a multi-purpose
multi-functional whereby
it could be used across the community
but the feedback we got
yesterday was in fact that wasn't the
case
but i think going forward from a
council's perspective with the cbd and
the developments we are having
the opportunities around school which we
should look at as a council at some
point but
just unfortunately this particular
proposal doesn't give that multi-purpose
multi-functional but i note from uh
on the recommendation um that community
well-being fund and the active
communities fund i think councillor
lewis made mention of that yesterday but
they're certainly welcome to apply
to that process thanks councillor scott
and as you know having looked into
the mobile scoreboards technology is
changing
rapidly and so i think we might find
ourselves in a position
soon but just not yet however they are
able to apply
to those two funds as as
the recommendations indicate
so it's been moved and seconded i'll put
the motion all in favor
against carried
h
it's really interesting to to watch the
changing parking patterns at turnbull
thompson park is a regular visitor
to there you know there's a there's a
little roundabout there that became a
parking plot
uh now i noticed vehicles going right up
next to the turf
there's a part of me that wonders
whether or not we should look at
employing the same
method that we did on alice road and
around saint andrews street that
because it's all very well if you've got
a four wheel drive it doesn't stop the
four-wheel drive from tearing up the
grass but there are people and some suvs
and
some cars that are making their way up
there as well and it's only going to get
worse over the next few months
councillor clark yeah just to reinforce
that um i've got a grandson that goes
there
last couple of weekends it's been
diabolical
and the trouble is that there's nowhere
else to park other than to park on the
grass just because of pure numbers
if you go back down the adjoining street
that runs in it's a very very narrow
street and when people park on both
sides and don't get their wheels up in
the curb
it makes one-way traffic difficult never
mind two-way traffic so there's a real
congestion in there it needs to be
resolved
because soccer is still one of the
highest
junior sport participation that we've
got
they drop out later than that but the
just about all the junior games are
played up there so there's
literally hundreds of people up there
said their moons it's it's packed till
about 11 o'clock then it starts
so we haven't got the wet part of the
season yet and when we do we're gonna
have a real messes unless we can resolve
some car parking
councillor sopa happy to move this one
mr chair
thank you and second to councillor
abbott
put that all in favor aye against
carried
just looking at the next two i and j do
we want to take those together
yep i'm happy to move both of those
thanks councillor anderson
seconder
councillor lewis
comment for or against
i think it's a cheer sorry i think it's
absolutely essential to look after the
safety of young children who may go
wandering while
the parents or the caregivers are
momentarily just
disrupted as ellis rate is a very busy
road um
so i think it's actually a no-brainer to
convince it whether or not we fence the
whole lot or just the playground area
i think possibly the latter would be the
the answer of that one with
with swimming ball type um gates that
were the high latches so
people can have access back out to ellis
radial
notice known parking there but perhaps
the bus stops or something similar
thanks and i'd support the request
that's come forward for a more joined up
um cycling network as well i think the
potential for that was pointed out in a
report
um maybe five years ago russell it was a
you know a while ago came through
parks um so we'll take the next step on
that
i'll put the motion all in favor against
carried okay
to remove her move that way mr chair and
counselor anderson
i'm just wondering whether it should be
an internal working group
or am i reading that wrong oh it's
written up there but it's not written in
here
that's i was down on yeah then on board
box
i'm looking in there yeah that's part
with all the commentary
no in the recommendation
i just wonder whether because this
obviously is a staff internal working
group
whether there needs to be some work done
at a governance level to
look at this topic to help feed into
that potentially about what the
priorities might be for
councillors
it depends on what you want the that
informed by i mean ultimately we're
going to need some information you're
suggesting that there could be a
governance representative on that group
no i guess i was meaning more that maybe
we need to have a workshop at some stage
about what's
the priorities for us when it comes to
climate change
wouldn't that follow from the general
working group yeah i would see it
following on from this councillor
partner
um i guess my question is around the
scope
of this group now there's two things to
look at here we've got
the carbon efficiency of council the way
it operates
and then there's also which is very
important to us
is sea level rise and that is happening
there is no doubt that it's one
centimeter a year
so uh the impact of sea level rise
we've got the flood banks being done
downstairs street
but it will impact on other areas we'll
change
perhaps zonings i'm not sure is that
so what's the scope is it just about our
carbon profile or is it
going into the greater district and the
effect on the district
rihanna um i can speak to that um
chair um so the focus of the group is in
the first instance to essentially
prepare this process for development for
the next
long-term plan and so as confirmed in
this long-term plan the strategy
approach is
first focusing on core infrastructure
and then
all other activities of council working
in alignment with
environment southland which i think
speaks to your point about alignment
with the rest of the district
so the first part of the work is really
building on our understanding
which is advanced on the core
infrastructure but building on that from
a risk
assessment point of view and so
completing that more detailed piece of
work
and then working from a full assessment
of risk into
mitigation strategies so um
at each stage we would be bringing that
back four
recommendations for council to give
direction
as part of the preparation for the next
long-term plan so that it may be as part
of that
that that's actually where the
governance aspect comes in
thank you comfortable with that yep
further questions or comments counselors
sorry
i'll put the motion all in favor against
carrie 4.6 saying that and confirm
all the changes required to the budget
as a result of changes to the operating
environment
um sorry could i recommend we go to
the recommendations under issue 8 first
and then return to
sorry my apologies
so 4.8 4.8 a
thank you so 4.8 a if we start with that
one confirming that funding for
operational support of the bluff pool
continue
at the revised level of a hundred and
ten thousand dollars and an operating
uh 110 000 operating grant and 10 000
capital grant
uh from next year yes
i'll take the two together sorry was
counselor scout seconded councillor kept
counselor rabbit no i was gonna move it
you're in support of it
counselors any other comments
there are none i'll put that all in
favor
against carried
48 cmd and d together
thanks councillor abbott is there a
second it for that
i would second that thanks councillor
lewis
open for discussion
there is none i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried
e and f councillor
cricket um just declaring an interest in
if
as my role as trustee in sport southland
thank you so i won't be participating in
the vote
zero mover
councillor pottinger secretary council
amundsen
it's open for comment
put that to the vote then all in favor
aye
against carried noting that councillor
cricket didn't
vote
g
i'll move that way mr chair
thank you
is there a second though i'll see you
there councillor evan
open for discussion
there is none i'll put that all in favor
against carried
h counselor amundsen
can i speak to this please and
um i'm assuming because there's three
recommendations under the same
block i'll take them together yeah we
could um talk about them together
um when um
this trust came to council previously
to speak to us they were asking us to
invest in the building and buy the
building which the council at that time
had no appetite for and i think that
remains the same
um this time in their submission to the
long-term plan
the request was more open in terms of
the support that
they were requesting from council and
i would really like to see us support
this project
in some way shape or form
my first instinct would be to allocate
a blob of money either
in one lump sum or over a period of time
over a couple of years
[Music]
because i think that this is a project
that will benefit
the community in the long term i know of
places
in south auckland where they have
community centres
there's one called randwick park that
i'm familiar with
and you know in high deprivation areas
these kinds of places
provide opportunities for for people to
do things that they otherwise wouldn't
have the opportunity to do
and certainly i know from the um the
community
rejuvenation i was involved in in
glengarry that
you know actually being able to have an
event in glengarry was really beneficial
to
that community because you know they
couldn't
easily access activities that were
happening in the cbd or in the wider
parts of the city
so i think on a number of levels uh this
is uh you know it's a worthy project and
ultimately
um you know something i would like to
see
um happen so if i may
i guess the alternative option to
allocating a blob of funding would be to
allocate
staff time to
to being involved and working alongside
to explore as an
eye but i wonder whether we could
just allocate a hundred thousand dollars
to this project
so just before we go any further i need
to make a declaration
um so my wife is a trustee on ic2
so i have an interest but not a conflict
i think my interest is sufficiently
removed that i'll cheer
remain in the chair but i won't vote
okay
so councillor edmondson were you
moving a recommendation yes i would like
to move that we
allocate a hundred thousand dollars as
part of the long-term plan
budget for this is that over a period of
three years a hundred
every year i'm happy to take advice on
that
what might work better so we might just
actually if we hold a motion at the
moment and i'll let a little discussion
go because it sounds like we're
but if he's so counsellor
clark then councillor abbott then
councillor passenger councillor ket and
councillor lush
so just reinforcing what big city i mean
i'm a supporter of this as well
um we've we've had some lobbying for a
hundred thousand times three years which
i don't support
but i think a hundred thousand up front
on the first year with a right to
um to look forward after the first 12
months to see what we're getting for our
money
so an air market that it can't be used
in purchasing a building which is one of
the areas that we were nervous about
buying a building that might be
earthquake prone
i think would be the way forward it then
allows this trust to
work with other potential funders when
they don't see us contributing
they don't see it as an important need
and i think we need to make a statement
about that
i've also traveled around the north
island recently and seen what begs have
seen in auckland
which is a lot of these high deprivation
areas have got these community
centres or community hubs as they refer
to it gives a connection that wouldn't
otherwise be there because the people
who live in those areas don't have the
ability to be mobile into greater
greater areas so i'm very much in favor
of a hundred grand
and the initial year with some ability
to come back in years two and three
without any commitment to that
counselor abbott yes well the
organization was speaking of is
community orientated very very
very very successful and projects well
i'd like to support it too but i am
inclined to think that a hundred
thousand dollars for the first year
um with the ability to apply for a
hundred thousand for the second in the
third year would be my preferred option
and i'd like to see them succeed
councillor pottinger yep following on
in support but i guess my supporters
from uh this from a reason i got um a
great motivation yesterday from a
comment from a fellow counselor it was
about
we're spending all these millions on
infrastructure and very little on people
councillor kit yeah thank you truman um
i um what i was going to say councillor
abbott covered that so
uh i would support the 100 by 100 by
300. councillor lush yeah i'm just
slightly confused it seems to me that we
don't want them to buy the building
because the building is
earthquake earthquake we don't want to
be involved with that but without the
building
what is the community apart from
a donation from the council to to ease
their conscience i don't really
understand
what that money would be gone to so my
understanding is that they would uh the
group
the ic2 group would buy the building
um and that our contribution would be
used
towards the refurbishment and the
setting up of the activity
so we would be paying we would be
enabling them to buy this building which
seems to be not fit for purpose and
surely they could do i mean
i don't i yeah i think i think we're
enabling them to do whatever we want
when no group came yes i was
yeah so i think their initial um ask
when they came last time was for us to
buy the building and to lease the
building to them
um council didn't have an appetite to do
that
but this is about helping them in a
different way so that they can still
achieve what they wanted to achieve but
not with council owning the building
their plans include
the refurbishment and rebuilding of
parts of the building so that they can
so that it's no longer it's quite prone
and that it's fit for purpose
what they want standard as well
councillor thank you through your chair
um
just following on from councillor
partners i just wonder there's another
process that we could go through in the
sense of
um opportunity around perhaps the lease
arrangement we could have
or enter into i've been down and had a
look at the building it's not in great
repair to be honest
it's not fit for purpose at all and
those sorts of buildings as we all know
it require
it's an ongoing process to be honest so
just
from being prudent from a rate by our
point of view if we could and even a
pilot scheme
and look at a pilot scheme over a period
of time where we could we could then
join with other
contributors and we had a clear message
from other funders if we became a part
of this
we know that the other two funders are
very supportive of the process
so we could have a combination we could
form a pilot and we could work alongside
the group to get a really good result
going forward there's no question we're
hanging a hat on being a city of heart
it's been said to me up until this
recent council that
the likes of south city and bluff are on
life support
are on life support you know i'm an
advocate for people
and they are best assets so project's
very worthwhile i just think we need to
take a pause and make sure we get the
structure around if we are going to
support how we support
and what will be the best result for the
total community around that that's all
so that's why we haven't um taken a
dollar around as yet because we have to
look at
conditions council of sopa thanks mr
chair um like councillor lush and
councillor scout
i'm interested in what we would be tying
an amount to is it the delivery of youth
services which is mentioned
in jay or is it the delivery of
community services
is it a trial project of youth and
community services
i'd just like there to be a little bit
more certainty before there's a
an amount of money tagged um
that it's that it's being tagged in a
way
we would like to see the delivery of so
i'm not i'm not adverse to to saying
um it's a worthy project i think i think
it is um
i think we've we've expressed in various
forms that
this council is not particularly
interested in
investing in another old cold
building that it's very uncertain
how much investment you would need to
improve it but we are very interested in
the community
and youth aspects so i'm just interested
if we're talking about a sum of money
that we're a little bit more specific
about
what council would like to see that used
for and
what councillor scout mentioned of a
possible trial
of a service may be a way to um
tag that so if council is going to
allocate a sum of money to this in any
form it's going to do so today
okay councillor edmondson then
councillor lash
could the recommendation therefore
uh include something like uh that the
money is not to be used for the purchase
of the building
but could be used for
the refurbishment and could it also
include
something to the effect that that the
other funding
for the completion of the project has to
be
guaranteed before we pass over the money
to ensure that one we're not
then investing in a building
which was uh which was the direction we
gave earlier
and two that
it's only invested or the money is only
given if the project
secures all the other funding it
requires
i think contingent on other funding is
fine but we're starting to get quite
complex yeah
i'm going to come to michael for some
feedback financially very shortly but
councillor lush
i think the optics of this looks
terrible i think we've gone ahead with
them all and looking at the art gallery
for 50 million and we
are enabling the people of a high
deprived area to go into a
church an abandoned church that was save
mart
for a youth hub i think the deprivation
of problems there are
what we here they are i think if
anything we should be
helping them in a process to um
fundraise some sort of new building look
if this is all we can do i'm not opposed
to doing this but i think it's um
i think in light of the other things
that we've done in the long-term plan i
think it looks
um i think it's it seems to me to
appease the council
i mean i don't i don't think it's a very
grand gesture and i think it's probably
what's
required for that area and i think the
intentions well
i just think that we've run the risk of
enabling them
and giving them a hospital pass bearing
in mind if this is the only chance we've
got to give them money like the chair
says
then i accept that but
i worry about the long-term success
of that if this is what we're doing
michael is this a time when you want to
have a comment or deal
are you looking for a more firm
direction from councillors
through yourself the chair um you
do need an indication of um whether we
want to commit
a hundred thousand or over one or three
years or not at all
um that does have an impact in relation
to the rates
of a magnitude so it needs to be weighed
up with the financial impact that would
have over the wider
community as well so okay so counselors
we've had a reasonable
sort of a round table uh to kind of get
a feeling of where things are and now is
the point we're going to say we get to
have to test the water
so we don't have a motion
right we'll just have a brief
adjournment while i come to terms with
some information
yes councillors if i can just uh get
your attention i'll i'll reconvene
sorry back here
a suggestion uh from mrs hadley and
and what it is that we're trying to
achieve
thank you mr chair i'm very mindful that
the long-term plan
sets the direction for 10 years but
there is of course the annual plans that
we do in those off years so to speak
listening to you i'm wondering if it
would reflect the mood
if it was to say that council allocate a
hundred thousand dollars
for officers to work alongside ic2 trust
for delivery of youth and community
services
and request a report back to ppp at its
july meeting
around appropriate conditions on that
funding
they're happy to move that would be yes
work for everybody is uh there's lots of
great murmurings going on so councillor
amazon's just moved that
councillor partner will you see to speak
briefly to the to the support can i get
it can i get a second to first
thanks councillor yep yeah it was just
to the summary that was in jeanette's
presentation and it's quite
straightforward our request is that you
make it possible
by supporting the concept facilitating
dialogue
and contributing to the seed funding
required to stimulate other funders who
have already expressed
considerable interest and i think that's
what the motion allows us to do
are there any questions around it even
though it's still going up there
okay i'll pause
[Music]
it's about committing an amount of money
just trying to just
um
that keeps it moving right
there we have it counselors
there's a question or comment counselor
clark
not wanting to be too pedantic but just
wanted to be clear that the 100 000
is not for us to use in in working with
them it's really
us to bring back some report to july
that would
open the door for them to have that
hundred thousand
the intention is in fact you could say
that council allocate a hundred thousand
for officers to work alongside ict
to trust to shape a grant yep
for delivery yep thank you
yes okay i'll put that all in favor
i saw alan's mouth moving i'm sure he
was saying yes
uh if we could note that i abstain from
that vote thank you thanks councillors
that brings us to 4.8 k
now hang on yes
funding request with nzta for the
continuation of the role
happy to move that mr chair if we just
add the name of the role
yes looking for the role thank you
role
moved second to please counselor cricket
um just a note to abstain again
okay again related to sports southward
thank you sir a second thanks councillor
rabbit
open for discussion
there is none i'll put the vote all in
favor aye against
carried uh
i l
sorry small
l happy to move l and m together
mr chair i'm happy to second both of
those
mr chair can i just make the point for
uh councillors and members of the public
that the from 220
or from 250 is what is in the current
year's budget we were being quite
transparent about those increases
thank you increase of 700k so we had a
mover and a seconder
yep discussion
against carried
all right rhiannon i recommend you now
move to recommendation five before
coming back
to four point seven thank you
for move recommendation
move councillor abbott second to
councillor partner
it's there for discussion
there is none i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried
likewise i recommend six
well not quite there yet we're going
back to 4.7
i think where were we 4.6 a
no 4.7 first 4.7 sorry
i'll move mr chair all of it
uh the hole of 4.7 a with all its sub
clauses
four point seven a moved councillor sopa
secondary councillor clark 47b
and and i'll include 4.7 b for
completeness
thanks councillor clark you're happy
with it
yeah i'm happy with that thank you it's
there for discussion
sorry we're jumping around a little bit
but it's all going to work in the long
run
no comments i'll put the motion all in
favor
carried this time
so bring us back to 4.6 thanks
so 4.6 a
now it can confirm all the changes
required to the budget as
as a result of changes to the operating
environment
which we might as well go through the
next few
any amendments required to these michael
all right b
c
i'm happy to move one of those
how far through have you gone sorry let
me just check 4.6
a b and c thank you
abnc it's been moved
councillor amanson seconded council
abbott
there's no comment i'll put that all in
favor
against carried
4.7
done mr chair sorry it's been done i beg
your pardon
gosh
did we do i yeah we did
and we've done five i'll move
six
or second six
it's been moved and seconded and opened
for discussion
there is none i'll put that motion all
in favor
aye against carried
okay councillors so i made the comment
to a couple of
um people during the morning tea break
that
this has been the biggest long-term plan
project that we've gone through we
talked about the scale of it
of it earlier on i also want to touch
on the engagement that we had in
pre-consultation and through the process
reflect on the submitters who appeared
in front of us
many of whom we'd not seen before which
goes to show some success through that
engagement
and also reflect that those who didn't
appear in front of us but bothered to
to write or take part in the online
feedback that's also
been taken into account and and being
read by councillors
this isn't my observation in my time on
council
the most open engaged and transparent
long-term plan process that that we've
been through as councillors
it is a process that staff have always
gone through
and have continued to do so diligently
but by crikey councillors the hands have
been on the wheel this time
and we've gone through an open meeting
and debated everything today and i think
you should congratulate yourself on the
manner of the discussion
uh we haven't all been in agreement um
but that's just
actually a part of of how we do business
when there's disagreement that actually
reflects the different views that
that exist within the community um
there have been many people who have
made submissions with points of view or
suggestions
that might not have been uh adopted as a
part of of the resolutions that are
going forward to council on the 25th of
june
that absolutely does not mean that they
have not been heard
because they have and they've formed
part of what it is that we've considered
and discussed
so thank you for that um thank you for
staff who now have some
ongoing work to to go through um
and at this stage mr grant i'll hand
over to you for a quick comment
thank you cheer look um i just wanted to
make a comment in regard to the process
as well and firstly darren councillor
hello in terms of the way chad when
lindsay and i took on this role
the ltp was the biggest issue in the
thompson report
and i just have to say uh we met with
rihanna at the first part of that
process and came away very confident i
i just want to acknowledge like you did
mr chair
from an external point of view we've
been both impressed by the staff
and the way they've provided the
information but more importantly i think
the way councillors have worked through
the process
and i'd have to say in comparison to
some other ltps i see around the
countryside
this has been a very impressive process
and i congratulate you all i think it's
it's been a pleasure to be part of it
thank you
thank you councillors members of the
public and staff thank you for your
engagement throughout today i am
going to officially declare the meeting
closed you have the afternoon to do your
will
keep warm and drive carefully
you